in the last video we started with the
story of the patriarchs in Genesis how
Abraham settles his people in Cannon but
eventually they get enslaved in Egypt
and according to the Old Testament that
enslavement lasts for over 500 years
until we have the emergence of Moses
whom we also spoke about in the last
video and the next four books of the
Hebrew Bible which are often given
authorship to Moses these really talk
about Moses freeing the Jewish people
from enslavement getting the
commandments the the the law from God
and eventually bringing the people so
that they can resettle back in Canon and
as I mentioned in the last video these
first five books of the Hebrew Bible
also the first five books of the
Christian Old Testament they are
referred to as the Torah and they are
given authorship to Moses although
historians are doubtful of that and even
the historicity to the degree to which
to these our historical characters are
significantly debated but we have the
Jewish people according to biblical
accounts now in Canon and as we go into
the rest of this video we're getting
into more of a historical period with
the first significant kings of the
Israelites so now we're getting into the
first millennium BCE the people the
Israelites are settled in Canon and
around in the 11th century BCE you have
King Saul comes to power and he's
considered to be the first significant
king of the you or the first King really
of a United Kingdom of Israel and Judah
so this is King Saul he was then
succeeded by King David and it is who
was his son-in-law but it was a very
contentious succession and David is
considered a significant figure in
Judaism and Christianity and Islam he's
considered a warrior poet philosopher he
really strengthens and really unifies
the kingdom
and then he's succeeded by his son King
Solomon and King Solomon was is famous
in biblical accounts for his wisdom and
he's also known for creating the first
temple in Jerusalem and as we will see
this first temple in Jerusalem the way
that I've marked it off on this timeline
the green is periods according to
biblical accounts and then later
according to historical accounts as well
when the Jewish people were for the most
part not in Canon where they were in
captivity or they were being enslaved
there were an exile someplace else the
white that I show here and so this is
the enslavement in Egypt and this is
going to be the Babylonian captivity
that we're going to talk about shortly
and then the white this is when we have
the existence of the temples in
Jerusalem
so the first temple in Jerusalem this is
a depiction of it was started it was
built by Solomon now this the the
unified kingdom of Judah and Israel all
don't last beyond these three kings
shortly thereafter they get it gets
fragmented into two kingdoms the kingdom
of Judah and the Kingdom of Israel and
the Kingdom of Israel is going to be
overrun by the neo-assyrian in 722 when
they refused to pay tribute to the
neo-assyrian king and the kingdom of
Judah essentially becomes a client state
of the Assyrians it's important to keep
in mind even though these are called
kingdoms for most of these history their
client states to larger powers whether
it's the Assyrians the Babylonians the
Egyptians the Seleucids they keep being
client states but they are also have
some degree of autonomy which is why
they're called kingdoms so in 722 you
have the Kingdom of Israel being overrun
and many of the Jewish people having to
go into exile and being held captive by
the neo-assyrian and then as we get into
the sixth century BC
you have the famous Babylonian conquest
the neo-babylonian conquest of
nebuchadnezzar ii who conquers judah and
once again this is really a side battle
between the NiO Babylonians and the
egyptians and we talk about that in
other videos but that takes us to the
Babylonian captivity so this is a
picture here of Jerusalem and maybe as
equally important that first Temple of
Solomon being destroyed and the Jewish
people being taken into captivity where
they are taken from Jerusalem where they
are taken from Jerusalem to Babylon and
they're held in captivity a significant
fraction of them are held in captivity
in Babylon from this period from around
597 586 BCE until Babylon is conquered
by Cyrus the Great conquered by the
Achaemenid Persians that we talked about
in another video and so once again the
end of the captivity is really a side
effect of larger battles and conquests
going on but Cyrus the Great he frees
the Jewish people in 538 BC this is the
end of the Babylonian captivity and he
resettle them back in Jerusalem and they
he also assists and his successors
assist in the rebuilding of the temple
and so then you have the Second Temple
of Jerusalem and you often will hear
Second Temple Judaism because this is a
period now where the Jewish people are
resettled in Jerusalem they are
rebuilding that second temple that a lot
of the Old Testament takes its modern
form now this is going to last for
several hundred years as I mentioned the
Kingdom of Judea is a client state of
all of these various empires and
eventually becomes a client state of the
Roman Empire as we get into the as we
get into the end of the first millennium
BCE and as we get to 70 CE II so this is
shortly after the time of Jesus you have
the first Jewish role
sometimes referred to as the Jewish
revolt and in that the Romans are
destroy the Second Temple and this is
really significant the Second Temple
which as we mentioned it starts getting
rebuilt at the end of the captivity and
famously gets really nicely constructed
as we get into the first century BCE but
then in 70 CE II Jerusalem is destroyed
again this time by the Romans and this
begins the beginning or this at the
beginning of the Jewish Diaspora where
they are they are exiled for now we're
talking thousands of years from Rome and
they spread through the Roman Empire and
other empires and we talk more about
that in other videos and this is a
significant thing because now the Jewish
people are for the most part dispersed
they don't have a temple and you don't
see a significant resettlement of the
Jewish people into this area until we
get to the twentieth century